no you did it perfectly ani malachi um
thank you
very very much uh chairwoman ober and to
the rest of the committee
um am i beginning now or you are
it's up we have your handouts and for
the two people at home
it's up on the lba website so we
appreciate you being with us i
understand you have
a committee meeting of your own at 1 30
so we're going to try to be quick
efficient and get you out on your
schedule and thank you for coming
excellent thank you very much for this
opportunity to
be before you today also
just as an aside kathy
carr from the department of justice may
also
chime in or tune in here in case there's
some
additional assistance i might need um
with this being my
second budget hearing still a little new
but as you
may or may not know as of 2012 fiscal
year 2020
the human rights commission is
administratively attached to the
department of justice
so there's some um back of house items
that they provide coverage for us
okay i just moved kathy carr over so if
you need to talk to her she is with you
excellent thank you um so i'll just take
a few minutes here and talk about
uh who we are as a commission and what
we do so that everyone
uh so that we're all on the same page
here
just by way of a little history the
human rights commission was established
in 1965
by rsa 354-a for the purpose of
eliminating
discrimination in the areas of
employment housing
public accommodation and in education
more recently
the commission is comprised of seven
volunteer commissioners
who provide oversight and make decisions
on charges of discrimination
each commissioner is appointed by the
governor with the consent of the
executive council
for a term of five years unless someone
is filling in for someone else's term
and they complete that term and then
there would be a renomination should
that person decide to
continue on with the commission in a
nutshell what we do
is the commission has the power to
receive investigate and
pass upon complaints of illegal
discrimination
and to engage in research education and
community outreach
so designated to prevent discrimination
as it states in our statute in addition
to the authority vested in the
commission by rsa 354-a
to enforce new hampshire's laws against
discrimination the commission also
partners with the u.s
equal employment opportunity commission
also known as the eeoc
to enforce federal laws prohibiting
discrimination and employment
as well and we have a small office of
we may be at nine right now um so we're
certainly here to discuss that
a little bit of information and um
one of the things that a couple of
things that we are looking for
in this new budget that are listed as
our prioritized needs
is to reinstitute the funding for our
administrative assistant
um to re
well to reinstitute funding for one
other part-time position and that would
become an
intake coordinator that helps us
in bringing in and doing just the
initial
we could say investigation but the
initial conversation with someone who is
potentially filing a charge of
investigation
funds for our doit shared costs and
on the way on the wish list would be the
adding of a brand new position
which would be a person that would be
responsible
for our for creating and administering
our
training program which we are able to
charge
fees for and able to bring monies in
that go back into the general fund so
with that i've include
i conclude my initial testimony i do
have the
answers to the questions that you posed
and i
am ready to move through that as uh as
as you all would like thank you i think
i think you covered the first three
questions you don't have any new full
staff and two positions were unfunded so
you did that very nicely in your initial
um and you gave us a description of what
they do
including the part-time intake
coordinator
um did you speak to
the doit item
i did question 7b
yes bear with me one moment
um usually what doit will do for us
is to assist
the commission with a variety of items
that we
should um either update or or make
changes on
as um as time goes on
and what they have for us in our
prioritized needs um at the
majority of it is just our to fund our
shared costs
for doit so there wasn't anything
more specific than that okay
all right so your budget starts on page
goes to the end of 323 and basically as
you testified
you're using slightly fewer general fund
dollars because you have unfunded
positions
and you did that to meet the
requirements basically of the pandemic
that the governor had to
respond to questions of the
committee for this malachi
representative walls thank you very much
um
i have several questions actually um i
ask
so what percentage your money is general
funds and what how much of a general
fund cut did you have to take
so um our the percentage we are
about 85 percent general funds and so
the balance of that is
um helped with our contract with the
eeoc so roughly 15
and um you know i don't have the
specific percentage
uh relative to the quote-unquote
cuts i mean we just we just didn't hire
a couple of people back so we didn't
certainly have to let anyone go
which at the very least is good
uh that was another question i went
ahead so thank you oh okay
if we were to level fund you how much
more would you need
so i would if you look mary beth at the
bottom of page 323
she had adjusted authorized
forty 813 dollars in fiscal 2021 which
we're in
in 2022
she's at 765 and 157
thousand dollars or but in
2023 she goes back up slightly above the
adjusted authorized for 2021.
you see that at the bottom of page 323
in your general funds
okay i do source of funds
all right i'll come back to that and i
have one more question while i have the
floor
um and that is in your answers to your
questions you say that we should
um eliminate let me find the exact
wording
um
so i thought that we should suspend some
things because we're not funding it am i
misreading that am i quick read here
um on i think you're referring to thank
you for the question
uh representative walsh um i believe
you're referring to question number five
which was in response to it was the next
part of four
there i i'm not suggesting that any laws
should be suspended i think
the only thing uh one of the things in
our statute is relative to the time
frame
uh for us and um i would
potentially think that's what you're
specifically referring to or what the
question is
is referring to um i don't think any
laws should be suspended
well that was it if just if anything
needed to be suspended my question was
what
that's all oh uh no i don't think so
thank you for the follow-up and the
clarification
um no i don't believe anything should be
suspended
thank you uh that's my questions madam
chairman
representative thank you madam chairman
thank you for your presentation just a
quick question
on the bottom of page 323 under
estimated source of funds for
enforcement
009 agency income
could you clarify on that as to you're
not getting any more
income and what type of income that was
please certainly um
the income that we generate it's it's
two things
um it's so i'm not including federal
funds um
what what that line specifically speaks
to
is training that we provide and when we
provide
training we do um get paid for that
training
and um the other source of income is if
people are in need of duplicate copies
of
of their files for any reason we provide
no cost up to a certain number of pages
and then after that
there is an administrative fee and a fee
per page for the
for the duplication and um
and then there would be you know money
paid to uh paid to the commission but
certainly when it's deposited all of
that goes back into the general fund
follow-up sorry thank you for that
um uh you mentioned uh training
uh and there's no funds for training
given the importance of your department
why haven't you allocated funds for
training in the future
oh i apologize um and thank you for the
question and for the follow-up
um the the zeroes there are the income
so it's stating it what that's showing
is that we're not projecting that we are
going to do x number of training so it's
not
training for the for us it's training
that we provide
if any agency uh any businesses contact
us for training
we certainly will make training
available
and sometimes it is a part of
a mediation or it could be a part of
the the closing of a case
that a business or an individual may
need
um a variety of trainings i mean
the majority of what we provide is
sexual harassment training
and so with that being said if we're
if someone reaches out to us and
requires training we will absolutely
provide that and then that will come
that the finances for that
or the pay for that will come in however
we're not actively attaching
a dollar amount that we're going to do x
number of trainings
which is why that line is at zero did i
answer your question
yes thank you for that clarification i
appreciate it thank you
representative walls does your hand back
up or did you not take it down
okay i didn't take it down i apologize
again that's okay i just want to be sure
you got to ask all your questions no
problem
i appreciate it thank you madam chair
any other questions
miss malachi thank you for coming
you are done we appreciate you coming
and we appreciate you being so well
prepared and now you can go on to
you have a little brief pause before
your next meeting
justice gosh i appreciate all of the
questions and thank you very much
chairwoman ober and you all have an
amazing day thank you you're welcome
bye bye-bye
i think we could approve this budget
representative emmerich moves to approve
the human rights
commission budget as presented by the
governor and representative griffin's
seconds
is there any discussion to the motion
seeing none the motion on the floor is
to approve the human rights commission
at budget as presented when the clerk
calls the role if you're in favor please
say yes
if you are against please say no okay
madam chairman yes vice chairman
emmerich yes
the clerk votes yes representative
griffin yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch
yes representative walsh yes okay
affirmative nothing the motion is
approved unanimously
i'd like to ask the division members to
turn to page
26 in hb2
specifically item
this is the department of corrections
transfer authority
that allows them to transfer money from
certain classes
into their overtime line if needed as
the biennium goes on
as you know commissioner helen hanks
spoke to that when she was here
they asked to have it in it is in we did
not
discuss it at the time is there any
discussion
on this item i'm sorry madam chair i've
got page 26 but can you tell me which
number again please
56. thank you very much two sixes in a
row sounds like the same thing almost
thank you
moves to adopt section 56
of hb2 representative leishman's seconds
any discussion on the motion
scene none on the motion to adopt
section 56
in hb2 when the court calls your name if
you're in favor please say yes
if you're opposed please say no
okay madam chairman yes vice chairman
yes the clerk votes yes representative
griffin yes representative
representative hatch
i think you're muted sorry yes
we okay we're having a hard time hearing
again suddenly part way through the roll
call
i'm sorry represent waltz yes now i can
hear you and the answer the vote is yes
okay sorry about that thank you
section 56 is unanimously adopted
i would like to ask members of the
division to please turn to page 40
and this time it is section 75.
this is the section that provides a
grant
for two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
in the first fiscal year and two hundred
fifty thousand dollars in the second
fiscal year to the new hampshire
internet crimes against
children fund this is a pass-through
grant
that as we heard when doj was here
is given to the portsmouth police
department
they have been in charge of this effort
in conjunction
with the state's attorney general
and counties they work across the state
for several years
this is another one of those
efforts where the language says the
governor is authorized to draw a warrant
for said sums out of any money in the
treasury not otherwise appropriated
representative leishman moves approval
of section 75
second representative hatch seconds
any discussion on the motion
see none if you're in favor of the
motion to approve section 75 when your
name is called please say yes
if not please say no madam chairman
yes vice chairman yes clerk
sorry the clerk votes yes representative
griffin
yes representative leishman yes
representative hatch
yes represent walls yes
motion passes unanimously
i do not have any other things in the
budget i want to address right now i
think
representative leishman is is working on
an amendment
for a section i've seen a draft we you
don't have that with you do you peter
uh nancy is that ready yet
are you talking about section nine yes
yes i sent it to you but you had a
question
that i have not gotten an answer to so i
don't know if you want to hold off on
that or not
yeah we can hold off and okay thanks
he's not ready he's waiting for his
answer
it is my understanding that the public
hearing on hb1
is going to be held on march 16th
i do not have all the details of that
but that is my understanding of what is
has been proposed and is going to
come forward
we have a full day starting at nine
o'clock tomorrow morning
if nobody has any additional
items at this time we will be
in adjournment mr hoffman if you're over
in the state house can you come up for a
minute
yes i was having trouble unmuting myself
i'll be right over
yeah well we all resemble that so thank
you very much
okay thank you very much for your work
today ladies and gentlemen and we are in
adjournment